when speed was released in 1994 an
action star was born
since then Keanu Reeves has appeared in
a number of action movies that had put
his abilities to good use some of them
are stone-cold classics while others
aren't here's every one of Reeves action
movies ranked from worst to best
based on the William Gibson's cyberpunk
novel of the same name
1995 s Johnny mnemonic follows the story
of a man with a cybernetic brain implant
that helps him store information as is
the standard for Gibson novels
humanity's reliance on technology and
the dystopian corporate environment of
this future keep people in a kind of
endless servitude Reeve stars in the
title role with supporting performances
from Dolph Lundgren and ice-t
sadly Johnny mnemonics premise just
isn't exciting to watch despite the
action being pretty heavy as Johnny
tries to recover his own childhood
memories that have been replaced by
years of data smuggling the main
conflict loses tangibility and no amount
of action is enough to make us care
about his plight Johnny mnemonic is
basically a guy running around a sci-fi
future trying to remember something he
forgot which doesn't exactly make for a
great cinematic experience 47 Ronin was
one of the biggest box-office bombs of
2013 the overly ambitious project
reportedly fell victim to a constantly
shifting focus in production and a lack
of experience on the part of first-time
director Carl Rinsch there was also a
debate around the project about the
balance between Eastern themes and a
perceived need for more Western touches
one of those Western touches was the
addition of Reeves to a mostly Japanese
cast of the film which retells an old
legend about 47 rogue samurai avenging
the death of their master what really
brought 47 Ronin down was that despite
its well choreographed fight scenes and
slick use of 3d and CGI special effects
the movie was surprisingly dull with
little to no development of Reeves or
any of the other one-dimensional
characters but don't worry Reeves did go
on to make another martial arts movie in
2013 that turned out much much better
than 47 Ronin will get their 1996's
chain reactions starring Keanu Reeves
and Morgan Freeman suffers simply from
being confusing Reeves stars as a
machinist who discovers some new
convoluted
about hydrogen energy before his lab
explodes and he and his colleagues are
framed for the bombing Freeman plays the
wealthy dr. funding their project to
whom they turned for help though of
course he turns out perhaps inevitably
to be the bad guy but much like Johnny
mnemonic chain-reaction has no tether
for the audience to grasp on to for
stabilization Reeves characters framed
for something that isn't clear while
Freeman's character is after something
that never really becomes clear either
it's a mess of a movie whose only saving
graces are a few good action sequences
there were a lot of these formulaic
action movies in the 90s was it all had
something to do with science or
government or spies unfortunately chain
reaction wasn't one of the good ones the
final film in the Wachowskis Matrix
trilogy has the benefit of bringing the
epic story to a close granting it the
opportunity to provide a rousing climax
enclosure to its philosophical journey
sadly that didn't save it from receiving
the worst reviews of the series largely
because it sucks pretty much all the fun
out of the entire franchise
not only does revolutions end on a
downer of a conclusion with Trinity
killed in action and neo sacrificing
himself for peace between the humans and
the machines but the final showdown
turned out pretty underwhelming in
itself the program known as Agent Smith
played brilliantly by Hugo Weaving wants
to destroy the matrix the machine world
and the human world for reasons that
never really become totally clear other
than that he's a broken outcast and
wants revenge
a rogue virus Agent Smith was apparently
supposed to be deactivated but has
instead decided to make it his goal to
kill literally everybody your life
taught me the purpose of all life
purpose of life is in amongst all this
the characters we know and care about
get lost in a jumble of side characters
overwhelming robot battle sequences and
convoluted plot lines the Matrix movies
can always be proud of their seriously
cool action scenes and intriguing ideas
but this one was a bit of a bummer
[Music]
Constantine is one of those movies that
should have been really cool but just
didn't live up to its potential based on
DC Comics Hellblazer books Constantine
tells the story of a mortal human who
can see the celestial angels and demons
who infiltrate and manipulate humanity
Rachel Weisz co-stars as a police
detective whose sister's death reveals a
plot that upsets the balance between the
living and the dead the movies got a
great cast including an androgynous
Gabriel played by Tilda Swinton and some
of the fight scenes that are really fun
too but ultimately the plot isn't one
that translates particularly well onto
the screen as a result the movie is
simultaneously convoluted and
predictable Roger Ebert gave the film 1
and a half stars while his TV co-host
Richard Roeper wrote it's just so awful
that the crew must have been snickering
while 1999's the matrix was hailed as an
exciting new entry into the sci-fi genre
with groundbreaking filmmaking
techniques it's two sequels weren't
nearly as well received as that first
hit the two Matrix sequels weren't great
mainly because much like too many other
films these days they felt like they
should have been a single movie but the
plot had expanded and bloated to the
point where the powers that be decided
to would be more exciting for audiences
the second movie in the trilogy 2003 The
Matrix Reloaded was praised for its
action and style but panned for its
portrayal of the humans who live in Zion
humanity's Haven outside of the matrix
one infamous scene in particular has
been subject to some pretty intense
mockery since the movie's release
between that and reloaded over reliance
on philosophical conversations at the
expense of the action it simply ends up
failing to live up to the first Matrix
movie despite Rives excellent fighting
skills many actors end up dipping their
toes into the world of directing but not
all of them are any good at it
thankfully Reeves first directorial
outing was actually pretty decent man of
Tai Chi a chinese-american martial arts
film is a love letter to the film star
and Reeves stuntman friend Tiger Cheng
and is inspired by his life and
experiences mana Tai Chi came out the
same year as 47 Ronin but managed to
avoid the same mistakes that brought
that movie down for one thing the movie
actually embraced its Chinese roots cast
an environment rather than shoehorning a
white Western viewpoint into an ancient
story the critical consensus was that
man of Tai Chi didn't do anything
groundbreaking per se but that the story
hearkened back to a style of martial
arts movie that hadn't been seen in
quite some time
which Reeves lovingly embraced and paid
tribute to in his directorial debut the
New York Times wrote the movie finds a
Janus like mr. Reeves looking in two
directions at once toward the old-school
kung-fu movies of once upon a matinee
time and the modern China emblem eyes by
the high-rises that slice through the
smog swath Beijing Reeves respect for
China and the style of filmmaking that
served as a personal tribute to his
friend is on very clear display here if
ever there was a spiritual successor to
Ted Logan of Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure
it's surfer FBI agent Johnny Utah of
Point Break the film directed by future
Oscar winner Kathryn Bigelow tells the
story of a gang of crooks known as the
ex-presidents because they wear rubber
masks of Nixon Reagan Johnson and Carter
while they rob banks they also happen to
the experts surfers so rookie undercover
agent Utah infiltrates their ranks
eventually embracing his destiny as a
wave rider in addition to having some
thrilling action and killer surfing
scenes Point Break is also a lovely
reminder of the acting talent of Patrick
Swayze who passed away in 2009 from
pancreatic cancer he was a beautiful
person an artist Patrick he just wanted
to experience life he lived life to the
fullest granted both John wick movies
are great and it's pretty hard to rank
one above the other John wick chapter 2
comes in just behind the first year
because the first acted so well as a
kind of surprise comeback film for
Reeves John wick chapter 2 begins just a
few days after the events of John wick
and finds the former assassin continuing
his rampage of revenge only this time
with a new dog the film features just as
much sleek well directed violence as the
first film but John wick chapter 2 also
takes a trip over to Rome for some
international espionage among the
ancient ruins of the Eternal City
proving that wick is truly a worldly
international assassin whoever comes
whoever it is kill me despite having
starred in numerous action movies John
wick might be Keanu Reeves grand opus of
a role this 2014 neo noir action film
tells the story of a former assassin
drawn back into a life of killing after
car thieves kill his puppy who was a
memento left behind by his late wife
this rule is absolutely perfect for
Reeves who sleep looks naturally stoic
nature and incredible action skills are
all put to great use in the movie
everyone was kind of surprised by how
good John wick was and how perfect
Reeves was for the part it was labeled
as a career comeback for Reeves who
started kind of dwindled a 20-17 birth
movie's death wrote it wasn't too long
ago that critics were bemoaning the
presumed end of Reeves career as a
leading man
but the John wick franchise has helped
bring Reeves back into the spotlight and
now he's calling the shots you are
working again no I just sorted some
stuff out never before and never since
has a city bus had such a grand movie
moment speed is the film that put Reeves
on the action radar and is still a great
watch 25 years later Reeves stars as Los
Angeles SWAT officer Jack who boards an
LA bus that's rigged with a bomb that
will explode if the vehicle speed drops
below 50 miles per hour Sandra Bullock
co-stars as a passenger named Annie who
takes over driving duties while Jack
tries to defuse the bomb and save the
other passengers
speeds premise is a tad ridiculous and
there are plenty of seriously
unbelievable moments throughout the
movie but its absurdity is overshadowed
by the fact that it's just so darn fun
Reeves and Bullock have great chemistry
and his action prowess here is
accompanied by a real sense of charm and
acting charisma this is the movie for
which Reeves will be remembered for the
rest of his life and beyond it's also
the franchise that put sci-fi masters
the Wachowski sisters on the movie map
by utilizing new filmmaking technology
and tapping into the exploding internet
zeitgeist the matrix was able to become
an action movie for the budding new
millennium Reeves stars as Thomas
Anderson a computer programmer who lives
a double life online as the hacker neo
as he's contacted by Morpheus and
Trinity he finally learns the truth
about the world artificial intelligence
has taken over the planet and robot
overlords use humans for their bioenergy
keeping them in a catatonic state while
their minds believe they are living in
the regular world this false
consciousness is called the matrix and
neo joins the quest to free humanity
from its grasp the movie used innovative
camera techniques to amp up the many
awesome fight scenes including
360-degree camera movement and extreme
slow-motion to make even more of a mind
bender out of an already interesting
premise by utilizing Reeves natural
stoic nature and sleek movements the
matrix became his best ever action movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]